there's multiple times i just i'll just
have them saved in as brunetting or stop
it no you do not where you from essex no
like ethnicity oh my family art saint
nation jamaican english
so like i'll just save units caribbean
language with nice jugs
oh my god
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views you know i was saying
it's all good
charm aren't ya and i've had some bad
dates how do you think you've done on
the date i don't really give a [ __ ] i'm
not gonna lie about it where are all the
decent men not in my dms that's for sure
you get me i feel like i'm rolling with
the man then what's going on about your
fives it seems like a lot of men don't
know how to treat a lady i'll just
manhandle everything and this guy's
putting a chest and chest in the nut
like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
my name's harrison sullivan i'm here to
drop loose game
i do this week in week out so it should
be minor when you've got a wine and
dining and you've got to do what you've
got to do you know i mean i'm not really
a dating guy but you've got to adapt
girls like to be taken out nowadays so
do you know what is a bit weird with
like other people being there but that's
the only different thing i do this like
all the time so i should be alright in
my opinion i just small talk ask them
about their interests and all that [ __ ]
i don't really care but you just gotta
act like you're interested
get to know them a little bit and then
then the night flows then you get what
you want
if they're like head over heels for you
then obviously you can just be straight
to the point but if they take a little
bit of graft then you can't just be like
do you want to hold my wood i mean that
won't work like do you have to grab to
get girls or is it just like what to get
them on the date or when they're on a
date
to get them on a date
just a quick dm mate
like clout helps dinner what do you
expect from a girl on a first date
to hold the word
[Music]
nice to meet you harrison nice to meet
you what's your name cheyenne
nice to meet you you're tall
six free oh nice
sick friends i like your dress as well
oh thank you like the jacket yeah it
looks nice probably better off to be
honest
yeah it's a little bit hot oh he's
confident yeah
is he taking his shirt off
that's more like it
are you flexing as you're doing that i'm
not flexing not like this you naturally
like pump
my pump anyway how are you nice to meet
you harrison
i'm not sure if i'm drinking i only
drink on special occasions
is that of course we'll see
yeah she's attractive she's got a nice a
nice rack on her you know what i mean
nice to look at for sure
fit
fit i'd say
eight point seven eight out of ten
if you want to keep it there will it get
creased it doesn't matter okay okay no i
don't care you don't get old season
don't care
i don't care okay so harrison tell me
about you
i mean i'm i'm 20 years old
so obviously i've got a little bit of a
baby face i don't know if you would have
guessed that but 20 years old do fitness
okay do a bit of social media and uh
that's it really what about yourself
okay just create content as well write
some things and i run a
project volunteers and stuff also you're
a charitable person then yeah yeah i'd
like to say so so my i went away to
argentina for a month to volunteer for
uh homeless people oh that's amazing
yeah a few years ago so i speak spanish
as well can you yeah hablo mucho espanol
what does that mean i speak a lot of
spanish
[Laughter]
firstly what are you telling me to say
um i think you're very nice
yeah
okay
boys translate that it's not what does
it actually mean which means i look like
you're very nice
yeah i'm trusting i learned that back in
argentina when i was younger okay i'm
trusting you
yeah is that actually spanish and what
did he say what did he say where's your
accent from
guess you i have a very distinct accent
i'm surprised you can't guess straight
away no it's i'm gonna say essex yeah
okay yeah i thought so i'm from essex
i'm from brentwood
oh okay what about yourself essex as
well are you yeah
have i not seen you around then because
i don't go around oh what you don't go
out at all no i'm a bit of a hermit oh
really like stay at home yeah and sort
of go yeah i'm actually boring i respect
that then so you're more of like wifi
material then you're not i'd say i am i
like that yeah i do like that yeah do
you want a wife
that's the question it depends really if
she's got what it takes but there's a
lot of things that they need to meet you
know okay what does it take then
well first of all like yourself i
wouldn't have a girlfriend that's going
out all the time well i'm not a
girlfriend but a wifey that's going out
all the time like that because obviously
if you're in the clubs all the time
some other man's just broken your back
every week i'll be real that that is
what goes on oh is that that's what you
do in the clubs
maybe definitely if i'm single what's
wrong with it there's nothing wrong with
it but i like an intelligent goal a god
i can have a conversation with um a
goddess got good standards for herself
so not a girl that's posting
loads of
tit pics and that on instagram for for
some lacks john i mean okay so a girl
that values herself has respect for
herself because if she doesn't respect
herself how am i meant to respect him
john i wouldn't say she doesn't respect
herself just by posting pictures though
i don't know i disagree to be honest i
disagree i think that there's a certain
type of girl that is on social media
constantly sort of posting
provocative pictures and i thought that
is not a girl that i would want to be my
wifey would i dm them yeah maybe
but
would i want to take them
on dates and stuff definitely not okay
what kind of pictures do you post online
just pictures of my physique really i've
seen you post body pics but women can't
well i think that there's a there's a
sort of difference there isn't there a
little double standard you mean big
hypocrite
not a double standard just a little bit
of a difference i feel like girls
posting
nude
would you call it new pictures not nude
but provocative pictures i don't post
provocative pictures i'm not
doing that sort of stuff just just gym
pictures i feel like there is a
difference though show me your
oh
instagram
then
banned last week oh you're banned are
you lying i feel like you're like are
you lying let me archive a few picks
really nice
my gram is uh just sort of so it's clean
it's not suggestive no no i like so if
you look from sort of
there downwards you can see doing
they're downwards what's above it
nothing's above it
are you serious
how are you guys saying just the odd
picture just the odds
i would look at this i know you would
i haven't finished i would look at this
and i'd be like this guy is not serious
for one woman right now i'm not but if a
woman come along who who ticks all the
boxes then why wouldn't i be joe i'm in
there's always i feel like there's in
life no matter who you are no matter
what type of guy you are there's always
a girl out there who could change you
from your normal ways for sure take that
back listen because this is a problem
that women do we have this like complex
where we the superhero syndrome where
you think you can change the bad boy
and you just said that it's gonna now
make women do a madness because no man
will change for a woman like that i
agree with that okay there are a lot of
girls i've i've experienced that who
will come to me and say oh like that
they think that they're the one who's
going to change you but there is that
that there is i think yeah you disagree
i don't completely disagree but i just
feel
it's not realistic well if you've been
a player from young have you you think
from 27 you can't meet a girl or like
not an age but when you're older or when
the time comes there's not going to be a
girl who stops you from being a player
or you think once a player always a
player well yeah i don't know if you've
seen any of my dates recently um i've
had a few players that are living the
playboy life even when they're like
reaching past 30. no i've i saw um i saw
i saw tate last week but yeah i haven't
seen any other ones yeah playing in the
car he's a party man
oh yeah yeah so not everyone
not every man will commit to a woman not
everyone wants to but maybe they haven't
found the right people okay and you
would
if it comes i would right now
maybe yeah
maybe it depends what sort of goal comes
along i'm not going to say no because i
haven't i haven't met the girl yet who
knows you could be that girl who knows
yeah could be your wife right now yeah
yeah we might be getting married in a
couple years who knows about it but what
you're doubting i can't lie
but who knows why do you doubt it
yeah she's she's absolutely loving it
spanish she's been creaming from the
second i've walked in you're gonna have
to ring the star for this restaurant get
a wet floor sign put down where she was
sitting because it's mad trust me
well i mean we i believe to know your
first job i mean i've got to it's got to
be a long process john i mean it's a big
commitment it is sharing sort of
business
letting people in i don't let people in
i've got two mates
one very close mate who's my business
partner that is it do you have like
commitment issues then
oh i don't know about that one i know
keep your circle small but to not have
any friends well we'll have to see
it's not commitment issues it's just the
more people you let in the more chance
that one of them switches up and do over
if too many people know your secrets
then too many people can can use that
against you and it's like i've got maybe
30 40 people who i'd speak to who if i
saw her out i'm like oh you're right
mate but that doesn't mean that my
friend that i'm gonna confide in like
with my my deepest secrets i mean and
troubles and problems
one or two people i think people with a
lot of friends they're always the fakest
people yeah so that's that's what i've
experienced people who are like oh i've
got 30 best friends no you don't like
you know what i mean and the girls that
say oh
like she's my best friend she's my best
friend like they're not yeah like
there's
they're not they'll snake especially
girls i find they're very uh they snake
each other all the time especially for
wood
what especially for my wood
moving man so women would snake their
friends to sleep with you of course yeah
really it's happened multiple times yeah
wait wait no that's why i say that so
technically you're the snake then i'm
not saying yeah you are how am i saying
so if you know they're friends you're
still going there with her yeah i could
be seeing someone not not going out with
them i could be i could be seeing you
for example
um and you've got a fit best mate yeah
and she's on to me not seeing you is in
a serious thing just just maybe sleeping
with you a little bit why would i not
sleep with her as well
no we're doing both no you're mad
so if we're seeing each other and then
my friend makes a move to you'd actually
go there not if we're in a serious sort
of thing
but it all depends under circumstances
as well because i'll say that and
realistically i'm lying a little bit
and i think most guys
like if they're being truthful would
probably as well wow if i've got a wife
and kids am i going to be doing that
definitely not well i hope not no i
wouldn't but if i've got if i'm just
talking to you if i'm just seeing you a
little bit
and your mate's there or someone else is
there i'd do it and i've done it
so yeah i mean like obviously she's fit
in that but if her mates want to hold it
as well
like i'm not going to discriminate they
can all have it there's enough for me to
go around
but it's the girl's fault it's not my
fault okay you need to take some
accountability
why why wouldn't you i have no loyalty i
i would in this situation i would have
no loyalty to you if i'm not we're not
going out i'm just sleeping with you but
if we've exchanged energy we are being
international
you're one of them ones yes what's wrong
with other than one
you talk about sleeping with each other
exchanging energy why did you laugh it's
an actual thing um don't know about that
all right listen one day you're gonna
sleep with some woman who's absolutely
crazy then watch when you embody that
then you'll look back and laugh and then
you'll hit me up shine you were right i
don't think that is correct i don't
think there's any real energy exchange i
mean
how is it not
all that energy exchanged [ __ ] i didn't
really understand what she was saying to
be honest i think it's a bit of stoner
talk
like
holding it is holding it all the
nonsense around energy exchange i don't
feel no energy exchange i don't get it
but
each to their own doesn't make sense to
me though at all
apart from the five minutes of exercise
10 minutes depending on no
how long it lasts i don't think there's
any actual energy exchange that i could
wake up the next day and not even
remember the name
that's just rude
well it's a fact though i think mom's
gone
can you not do that like no i don't
think you do women women we don't well
women do don't get me wrong but more
like majority time women don't and we
definitely remember the name i'm getting
the vibes from you that you're not like
you're not you're not a horrible are you
why would i sleep with someone remember
their name so what do you call them when
you're having sex with them
wood holder no you do not
no i don't i don't know
i don't call them anything you want but
i don't really call them anything like
if i know their name i'll call them i'll
say their name but if i don't i won't
like there's multiple times i just i'll
just have them saved in as brunetting or
stop it no you do not
that's
oh my god you're that's disrespectful
and does she know that you don't know
her name
why don't you ask her to say what's your
name big blonde jugs
fit brew netting
sinead one nighting
i think i think a lot of boys do that to
be honest yeah boys we'll stick with
them
boys
yeah this is what boys do
not men you want someone who's going to
wife you up yeah i can do that don't
worry i can do that it's just a case of
are you the right girl for me do you
even know my name where are you from
what's my name
sean
cheyenne cheyenne yeah essex no like
ethnicity oh my family aren't safe
nation jamaican english
so like i'll just save you know
caribbean lenguas with nice jokes
oh my god something like that
you know it was funny it was funny but
my name's cheyenne okay
it depends it depends how the date goes
maybe i'd save you in a cheyenne it
depends if we get to that so if you then
respected me you'd actually put my name
well listen to this to be honest we're
on a date right now so i'd probably save
you and as your name depending on how
this went but say i met you in the club
and i just took you back
which i think i'd do
you think you'd take me back
i'll have to meet you in the club yeah
okay
off the party nice hotel mayfair
that doesn't change anything
all right oh no i'd save you an is your
name because we're on a date
i'm more likely to remember like a key
word
like fit jamaican
lengus wow than your name there's loads
of girl names i mean there's not that
many cheyennes yeah true your name's
quite unique so maybe i'd maybe maybe
get a save
wow maybe i'd get my name saved depends
how your after club performance was john
i mean whether you get the name save or
not what
what about your performance oh don't
worry about that
where's your family from um so i'm guess
i'm obviously mixed rice
yeah mom
what
but
my mom is white white dad caribbean
no think of big wood what country would
you associate with it i don't know i
think don't i i don't think it's that
hard guess you have to tell me
i don't know
nigeria is it really yeah oh okay you
ever been there before no
i thought the girl was intelligent i
don't know what she's on about when i'm
giving her the name the first letter of
the country and i'm saying big wood
obviously nigeria but
i don't know she ain't got something
ain't working up there for us to not
have known that
my mum's irish english dad's african
yeah really yeah oh my god but i grew up
just with my mom oh really yeah my dad
was um
trying to go get the milk yeah never
come back one of them ones yeah still
waiting on that full fat milk
[Laughter]
so i've heard you've been cancelled
recently yeah i thought i was cancelled
as well what happened i'm joking i can't
be cancelled i knew i wouldn't be
cancelled i found it funny it gave me a
bit of attention what did you do
oh from your words i made a comment that
do i take that comment back yes what i
said was too extreme but
i'm a live streamer so i get one chance
to say something and once i've said it
it said
i said something about girls about black
girls it was a bit too far
do i take it back on camera yeah i do
does being just on camera in general not
like i'm saying it like to the camera
like yeah publicly i take it back good
because it was a bit mad i sort of
stereotyped
one type of girl as as butters apart
from a few well why'd you do that
well to be honest in my personal
experience my personal preference is
i like mixed race girls i like spanish
girls brunette brunette white girls not
really blondes too much and i've only
been with a few black girls because i
find
the majority of like fully dark skin not
that attractive to me
so i said that on live but i said it in
a way that
was it was too extreme it was actually a
bit it was it was hurtful
so that's why i take it back but the the
meaning behind what's not the meaning
behind what i said because that was too
far but the what i was trying to say was
that basically that my preference is
like favorite mixed race like white and
black mixed race and and and after that
others but i took it too far yeah
definitely did you see that no joe what
i heard and the thing is i've got two
things i want to say on that i think
like it's not me analyzing you but from
what i've based what i base it on um
black women are really beautiful i think
maybe because you didn't grow up with
your dad around you weren't exposed to
your black side of your family so you
don't get to see how beautiful black
women really are so that could be and
that's i'm not enabling your behavior
because that was wrong i think that's
completely incorrect
if you're thinking about if you're
around what your surroundings are when
you're around black women you'll see how
beautiful they are being around black
women
people don't understand like my best
friend in
in a secondary school from year seven to
year ten was a black girl like not my
best boyfriend but my best girlfriend
right and i was with her a lot was
around the house a lot was with her
family a lot it's like i'm not i'm not
racist at all like in the slightest what
i said
yeah but like i was getting people
saying that i was racist yeah like
internal like is it internalized racism
internal self-hating just [ __ ] like
that i was i was reading it just just
laughing thinking really like you
actually believe that of course i'm not
i have been around it not obviously not
family but i've been around it but i
don't need to
what what would me being around my black
grandmother have to do with me being
sexually attracted to black women i
think what it would do it would make you
just appreciate and understand also like
the
the micro aggressions towards black
women because for example like me as a
mixed race person like when we have men
that make comments like you make it puts
like light-skinned women up on a
pedestal which we don't we're not asking
to be put on a pedestal but a lot of
guys do that the way they do not want to
be on that pedestal why because it's
like it it then creates conflict and
opportunity for people to hate you for
no reason so it's like it creates this
colorism divide between black women and
mixed race women so that's why
you know but you're allowed to have your
preference i'm not saying you're not i'm
just saying like it's just things like
that where it just makes everything
complicated when it doesn't need to be
i've not been around spanish women i've
never been around a spanish family
however i think spanish girls are sexy
as [ __ ] yeah
yeah you can think that you can have
your preference but i think you can say
no but i'm saying you can say you could
have a type you don't need to bring
another type or race into it like you
say i don't like this you don't have to
oh because like a black girl is this or
this and that like i think it's you
can't just have a preference no and it's
not like it's not all black women who i
don't think fit there are a lot of black
women who are who are beautiful
obviously with mixed race people there
can be people that are mixed race really
clapped but just because they're mixed
race they're put on a pedestal and
glorified i completely agree if there's
an ugly mixed race ball you get
absolutely violated no you do no you
don't you get you get the highest mixed
race you get absolutely rinsed if you're
an ugly mixed race boy you guys no you
don't you get put up on a pedestal
whereas i feel like
if you're black or whatever you always
are just like put in a bracket where
you're like not wanting like men don't
experience that at all yeah because
they're fetishized like but black men
like
girls like black men that's not racist
that's just people's preference and i
was just saying that okay but i was
saying it in a way that was not yeah
it was
holding himself accountable which is
good and we'd like to see it so we have
to see how the date goes
what's your strategy on getting the
women interested in you for the jams i
don't really i don't try and get them
interested in me they're ever interested
or they're not i just dm
saying hello or the wavy emoji or yo
that's it you just send a wave so for a
date i'll just say yo she'll be like oh
hi i'll be like trying to come hakasan
next week next weekend yes of course i
am all right see you there hotel booked
i'll come pick you up in a twin turbo
lambo and we'll go there and women just
just accept that and go
of course they do like a lot of girls
aren't like you that's why as soon as i
had two minutes into talking to you i
realize you're not that type of girl
like you're
you wouldn't i know you wouldn't you
know i'd have to chat to you for weeks
on texts with [ __ ] that i don't care
about
it's not [ __ ] oh it is oh like what
did you do today at work how oh i'm
stressed harrison oh are you like
i hope you feel better all of that
nonsense and then like three weeks later
i'd be like can you come on the date
you'd be like oh yeah and you wouldn't
come to the hotel you'd probably go home
for the first few days i don't know
about with me that i thought i could
maybe get you back
no
it doesn't work like that you have to
you have to treat women with like
respect i do different goals demand
different levels of respect i'm never
rude to a girl i know you're not easy to
sleep with just by talking to you for 10
minutes or so but some girls
i'll dm and two days later they'll be
they'll be holding my word do you think
it's like a clout thing
since i've got clout and since what
people have seen that i do to the girls
who come on my page because some of them
i don't have that many followers but
some of the girls are going up 40 60 k
followers from a post so then when that
happened um there was a particular post
that just blew up
um
a lot of girls messaged me all like i
want to meet you this and that and it's
obviously clout um
but then like if they're holding it i
don't really mind to be honest if
they're fit which means i'll put them on
the install
oh you'll put them on your instagram
yeah if they're holding the wood i'll
put them on you hold it in the wood what
do you think
that in general
you don't in general just because i
don't know i don't know what's what's
been in there basically if you're real
fit
you might catch me giving head
like if you're real fit like i'm talking
9.9.2
plus out of 10
you get these lips but apart from that
nah mate i think it's quite a simpy
thing to do i think no that's my opinion
on it and i know you're gonna say oh no
it's manly i know girls love it but
i don't think i think it's something
that i save for
i think i've done it twice my whole life
with like two different girls my whole
my whole time since 14. do you like head
i love it yeah
i get head all the time like first thing
first things had
here we go again they like that dick
sucked but they don't do it to women
not on that
oh wow see these double standards would
you would you find it
like normal for me to just some random
girl i've met in a club to go back and
and lick a box
nah i don't know where that's been i
don't know if you don't know where your
dick's been yeah but i'm strapping up i
can't strap like she's not
if i'm licking her i could get anything
she's got but it's not even that it's
just the fact that i don't know if next
man was whacking that literally
yesterday i'm not trying to lick that
and get like oh no
they've got to be proper fit and i've
got to know that they're only sleeping
with me for
like a while john i mean i'd like if i
was seeing a girl for like a month she
was a rocket of course i would yeah
because it's like girls love it and i
don't mind doing it to be honest i think
guys that are just like going around
munching box i think it's really simpy
and
like oh
disgusting
i yeah i do actually do you yeah 100
like i would i would never i wouldn't
wife a girl with a body count of over
like
five over five yeah five no that's
actually crazy though like a long-term
wife and i don't know
it'd struggle if it's touching 10
it's like what you've let 10 guys
put their knobs in
how many people you sleep with though i
don't know but that doesn't matter
because it's like i it's different
honestly i'm actually sick of this like
how many more men have got to walk
through this door with double standards
no but even if it's different i feel
like you can i think you have to hold
yourself to the same standard
like i know i've listened there's been
enough men on the show that have said
the same thing but if yours is in like
over 50 and you only want her to be
on fire that's just a bit mad
i think a guy's body count is like
if it's with good looking girls it's
like a it's like um
like a i don't know what to say like a
trophy house it's like a good thing it's
like a good
it's like oh yeah this guy's this guy's
got it about him i think if a girl's got
a high body count it's just uh like
you're just tacky you're letting any man
hit do you think girls like it if you'd
slept with loads of women i think girls
think like instantly think that you're
good in bed if you have which could
attract them i think that girls find it
very attractive as well because it's
like if all of these girls have thrown
themselves at you like
i feel like gives them the urge to do it
as well like
that's my just from personal experience
i have girls i think like the fact that
i pull i think that makes more like it's
like just an effect it's like when you
make money you just start making more
money easily
no
you break up with me
why is your phone just on a madness i
just did you say yes yeah that's like
it's too
it's not even that that's sort of a joke
but like
it's the the control like that doesn't
need to be that aspect in a relationship
i wouldn't i wouldn't need the girl's
password because i know like why would
you cheat on me yeah well you'd only
cheat on me if there's someone that you
think's better if you think someone's
better see you later go get better it's
one of them yes one of them ones um the
other way around i know a lot of i know
i know a lot of guys who who do want the
girl's password but do you know what
it's always the guys that are asking the
girls passwords and the girls are
texting other guys like
i think it puts them off it's like
you're not you're a bit insecure it's an
insecure thing to be doing if you don't
trust it what you bring to the table is
enough to attract the girl then
you're just not who you think you are
and if you need to it's cringe it's
another thing i think it's cringe
checking your girl's phone off you've
been texting this guy have you been
texting this guy letter like let her
piss off of him do i mean i think i
think as well i'm quite a chilled person
so i don't really care like you can have
my password but i just think it comes
from
if you're having to ask to go through my
phone it shows signs of like no trust
and insecurity but i just feel like it
would just be a given like oh here's my
phone
if a girl was prestige and said look you
can have my phone password
maybe i'd find it a bit attractive
because i've been oh [ __ ] like she's
it's just it's more affirmation if i was
99 sure
that
you weren't going to do anything and
then you gave me your phone it's like
i'm a hundred percent just one of them
one so maybe
maybe i'd find it a little bit
attractive but it's not so i would never
ask because i feel like that lowers my
attraction so i would never ask
booty play
you can interpret anyway like massage
booty play yeah like massage or
something foreplay yeah oh yeah
obviously spice it up like yeah i
wouldn't do that on one night and i'm
like
i'm not massaging a bird i'm literally
i'm just lying there drunk like
letting her do whatever oh my god like
if i was with a partner
whatever she wanted i'd do it pretty
much like whatever but like that's it's
attractive sexual laughs nice but not
with random people i wouldn't be
massaging or doing any sort of like
foreplay right with a random never
never just a pump and dump with the
randoms can't say pump and dump it's
just a fact you need to start respecting
women i don't know you talk about them i
really do the same pump and dump is not
respectful pump and dump
is he sure
but it's just a fact though what's a
one-night stand from a geezer's point of
view it's a pump and dump
if you're taking a girl out on multiple
times that's when you start bringing in
this massaging and all of that
i'm not these hands ain't coming just
for any [ __ ] random bird i'm not
massaging one light stands that is
that's embarrassing
massage
what like a wood massage or like a
tongue massage or like a natural hands
massage yeah i'd do that if you've got
big bundle i wouldn't do it if it's like
an ironing board but yeah small bumps
need love no
no get in the gym do some squats
what
big bunda only really not massive
doesn't have to be like not a bbl but
like a nice cake that's juicy and moves
yeah i think most guys would say the
same no one wants to be of an ironing
board
that's dead
it should be illegal for girls to be
walking around with nobody it's an
absolute abomination to society
it's it's awful
like does anyone want to be with an
obese geezer probably not
that's someone who can't see their toes
like that sort of level of obesity like
probably no one wants to be with that
realistically
so it's like the same with a girl no guy
who's got options is going to choose a
girl with no ass
tits
like maybe some guys like them some guys
don't mind them i obviously prefer them
like decent like these double d's nice
really yeah ease but if they've got a
really nice ass it make up for it for
sure but i i just literally don't know
if you'd find a guy out there that would
that would
if he had options would choose a girl
with no ass it's like you're getting
with a boy in it no i feel like that's
not fair though because i kind of feel
where there's such a demand on women
that have this hourglass figure like
look how many women are just getting bbl
if if girls are saying they don't like
skinny guys guys just get in the gym and
fix it the girls can do the same thing
any girl can have a nice ass all they've
got to do is squat with good form over a
couple of years you will have a nice
arse really do rdls do things that
target your glutes you will have a nice
arse you will have a juicy ass yeah
exactly
any goal can achieve it and every girl
knows it's attractive so if you're
walking around with no arse it it just
shows me that you're lazy
oh you just don't care about men's
opinions on your body
why would you not care though like
why would you not like aim to be
attractive not everything is for the
male gays so no but it's like for women
as well women very women women even more
so it's like men with with good
physiques like you get i'd get more
compliments about my physique from men
yeah than women but and women are going
to get probably well i don't know
actually but they'll get a lot of
compliments from girls oh my god your
ass is so nice like you look so good
like and all of that obviously you get a
lot from boys as well but
i feel like if you don't have an artist
it's a bit like i think it's
embarrassing
i don't have a big bum and i i get guys
that approach me all the time it's not
about big it's about like is it juicy
i would not be able to walk be walking
into like a nice restaurant
holding a girl's ass and it just feeling
like bone like i just it'd give me a map
that's a big you know when you said
about red flags that is my biggest red
flag i didn't even think
no bunda oh
that is so bad
wow yeah i can't lie like i don't think
anyone who disagrees with me is being
true to themselves if you've got options
you're going to want to go with a nice
ass everyone likes to hold a nice ass it
just it's something that's attractive
about a female like a girl wearing a
nice dress with a nice body
yeah
beautiful
your car's nice how did you afford that
how did i afford it i was selling a lot
of training programs
that's that's all i've done until
recently to make dark
i'll get 20 30 000 people on a live at
one time really yeah that's really good
once was 62k or something that's insane
yeah so if you sell like 500 1 000
programs on a live they're 20 pounds
it's good
money you're very smart aren't you
people talking to me they don't really
get that but
yeah like behind the scenes i did well
at school yeah but that i don't think
that defines if you're smart or not
business smart yeah yeah
yeah
i know about business and that my mum
taught me a lot okay shout out to your
mum yeah shout out to my mom right
i've done well for that a lot of people
say there's a stigma around single mums
in that but
i think you can do just as well if
you've got a strong like a strong woman
bringing you up you can do well
definitely um what would your mom say
about you uh talking about loads of
women holding the wood you know when i
started she was like [ __ ] like you're
doing it this is this is like not the
way to be treating women like i got that
talk a lot of people think i didn't i
did of course i did i got grilled
all the time why are you doing this come
on like don't be treating women like but
it's not i didn't hop on the camera and
start doing this for views i was i just
hopped on the camera and did what i was
already doing so obviously i wasn't
getting girls featuring obviously
because i had no in-star but since i put
pictures up in me at 14 15 like doing
these get like i had pictures with girls
like the sort of pictures that i'd be
posting now at 14. stop it yeah there's
pictures on my end story of like like
two girls like doing my laces up at a
festival and me like pretending to whip
them and that
and this was like 15. oh my gosh so it's
like things from young i've been like
that sort of guy from young so now it's
just i'm just putting it on the camera
right so my mom like my mom has been
telling me about this about women since
a young like since secondary school but
i was always the cheeky guy at secondary
school at yeah i just loved it and you
still love it now yeah yeah of course i
do of course like any guy would love to
be doing what i'm doing right now like
literally getting paid well
to
be in shape and talk to girls that's
literally all i do like there's nothing
else
nothing else to my content really nice
cars
girls partying what made you like that
for women i can answer the fitness room
quickly i'm not saying in a sec but
women's more deep i don't know if it's
got anything to do with my dad like on a
on a deep level i've spoke to my mates
about this i'm not sure maybe because
like i don't know my dad was a rugby
player he got loads of gal
i spoke to him a little bit
got that sort of
i thought that i looked up to that in us
in a way but then it's like when you're
at school and you're getting girls
throwing themselves at you you sort of
just are like that as well and that is
literally what happened i mean i i had a
problem at one of my secondary schools
um
i was actually a private secondary
school a lot of people don't know that i
had a good good education but i got
kicked out of there
and i went to a different school and
then just all the girls were firing
themselves at me at like i think i was
15. so that is like where the goal sort
of comes from i think and just me
associating getting loads of girls with
being cool and that's what young boys do
the boys at secondary school who are
pretty normal just wanting to get the
coolest girls who got the most birds
yeah it's very it's it's like that isn't
it it's really weird yeah because it's
like it's who's more alpha really that's
that's the way at that age to define it
now now money comes into it a lot like i
i find when i'm out and i'm talking to
guys who are a lot richer than me like
wait like billionaires millionaires
multi-millionaires i'm like oh that is
that is cool but i'm i'm i'm looking up
to that but back at school it'd be like
everyone would be looking up to who gets
the most birds there's not really money
no one gives a [ __ ] about money because
everyone's using their parents money
yeah
and then with the fitness
literally i was 15 and i was 16. just
before like a few months before my gss
my mum just literally said to me look
you're looking skinny bro basically get
in the gym with me i'm going to start
the gym get in the gym trust me in two
years you'll thank me
and i was like yeah i just trust my mom
like i was like yeah you know what let's
do it i've never looked back i think
girls girls love muscle and now if
there's a if you're competing for a girl
competing but if you're if you're going
for a girl if a guy is skinny i think
muscley guy wins most times if he's got
the personality to match it it's perfect
yeah i think as well like i'm glad you
added personality a lot of big guys
thinking do not think it's just about
yourself a lot of gym guys have got no
personality like their personality is
the gym and they're just i've seen them
trying to like in the clubs and that
some people are not just stiff but if
you've got it as well then i think
muscles are a bonus she's talking about
our gym guys i've got no personality to
be honest i do agree with that to some
extent there are a lot of guys who don't
but come on now i'm the full package i'm
one she knows it i know it she's
creaming
[Laughter]
my muscles
um do you like my muscles i i personally
prefer like dad boards why that is such
a stupid trend of 2022. it's not stupid
it is it's like when you're laying like
if because if you're like got a hard
chest i'm just gonna lay on a hard chest
whereas like i'd like to just feel cozy
you could be close on these double d's
mate
bod i think she's just saying that to be
different and keep me on my toes to be
honest who is not going to want a
shredder over a fat
come on now someone is going to want the
shreds first hammy um how many people
are you seeing right now i don't like
see i don't see the same girls like that
i don't have like a so how many people
am i seeing i don't i'm not seeing
anyone
i've just like a few girls might text me
or dm me they could be
five new ones tomorrow
john mann he is seeing a lot of women
i'm not i don't have like a rotation of
girls who are texting that i was gonna
say no no no i just whoever whoever dm's
me or whoever i see or if i'm in the
club and i fancy someone
it's one of them ones just new ones all
the time keep it fresh do not get tired
is it not boring my job if it wasn't my
job i wouldn't be out like i am for sure
but it is my job i literally get paid to
do it so so you like your cars money and
women it's a bit like mr tate's
lifestyle
it's a little bit yeah i get a lot of
comparisons it's like i didn't actually
know this guy until two or three months
ago and a lot of guys oh yeah like
you're doing the same thing as tate i
wouldn't say it's the same thing it's a
bit different i think i mean for
starters i'm getting a lot more [ __ ]
if you look at me look at him like come
on now
um the cars yeah i like my cars i love
cars every guy likes quick cars though
realistically if you ask most people
most guys what they dream to have in
abundance fast cars women and and money
that's same as me for sure i'd actually
i'd like to scrap andrew to be honest
i'd love to see his face just getting
knocked out
just what's this well what's the verse
yeah
it's my brand head head yeah clothing's
dropping soon so everything i've got is
myself and ed he's my best mate business
partner so we just got a nice little guy
banged it on
yeah we've got loads of stuff dropping
do you smoke do you smoke
my car that's like anything
i've got cbd coming rolling papers
rolling trays you don't even smoke
cigarettes
i don't smoke cigarettes either actually
cancer sticks they're bad but cbd and
that can relax you yeah
you should try it it's
tight i need relaxing is that what
you're saying
i'll give you some samples you can try
it see if you like it okay but all of my
fans like they all smoke like weird
cbd so i just thought why wouldn't i
just do it myself and that's the same
with the girls side as well that's all
head head girls head everything yeah my
head girls head higher
head clothing that's cool he knows what
he's doing he's got a good business head
on him
what's the red flag for you the biggest
red flag i've ever like personally
experienced is a girl trying to flex the
money she makes on me
really i had a goal and a club going i
make 200k a year like and that's minor
like this this bottle means nothing to
me i was just like oh go away like i
just was like no
i think it's like
childish kind of yeah you're trying to
flex to pull someone to flex your money
i think is is a bit childish but i might
do it sometimes on live stream but not
as a joke that is i'll like over
excentrate all trying to get in my
lamborghini and then listen all the
words like performante spider there are
guys
in these mayfair clubs who i see
saying oh like they're literally showing
girls their cars yeah like to get them
back and that's like oh god it's i've
seen nothing more cringe and even girls
doing that yeah it's worse but
they've got to be like well kept as well
like that you see these rough girls like
rough looking girls definitely not
want too much sort of authority as well
i don't like it as well
i don't like that like girls want to
like be too dominant i feel like i don't
you take me you don't i'm ready
do you think i'm not tall oh i can be
though i feel like right now like it's
it's like 70 30 to me which is fine
really you're not like a pushover but
yeah i'm not you're not like trying to i
don't think you're trying to battle with
me i don't like it when girls do that
yeah that's that's another red flag
that's feminist i don't like feminists
i'm a feminist yeah but you don't seem
like a strong feminist i mean you got it
would you want to get the bill in a
restaurant i paid the bill
why are you laughing i have i think if a
guy lets you pay the bill it's quiet
that is that's not it didn't i think did
you oh so you're quite traditional
yeah
yeah like for sure harrison what would
you say is your toxic trait selling the
dream probably
at least you're honest how tell me the
dream oh you look beautiful cheyenne
yeah you said it right oh that is your
name i thought i said someone else's are
you laughing at my name now no i don't
know you've got a nice name i just
watched someone else's oh [ __ ] what is
her name i completely forgot i just got
too many girls on my line i can't even
remember
for real though i actually thought i
said someone who was from my phone i
didn't think my name was cheyenne i
thought i was saying someone else's name
oh yeah you look beautiful cheyenne i've
really enjoyed the day i feel like we
have a connection i've never met like
someone else with the same connection
that we have we vibe on just so many
levels i feel like we've got to go on a
second date and see where it goes to be
honest like i will cut off all these
other girls you're way above them in
looks personality literally everything
every every metric you're above them so
i think
a second date has got gotta happen so
that would not actually work
that would not work
why not women don't need you to be
little other women to make me feel good
if that makes sense like it wouldn't
work a lot of girls do no but like oh
you're i thought that's that's cap i
would see over there
you think i'm just chatting yeah i'd see
through that yeah but i feel like if i
said that to you in a club you wouldn't
i feel like if you're saying the club i
feel like you crave if i said that i
thought it'd be like oh my god like
no i definitely wouldn't i was so nice
definitely wouldn't it because then i'd
be like didn't you just say that to all
the other girls that i've seen you have
tonight that's what i would say well if
you was the first girl the only girl
than that yeah
no do you know what my um tactic i don't
go clubs but when i used to
i am my tactic would be if you asked my
number to start the night i would say
i'll come and find you a little while um
then i'd observe you all night there and
then i would see how you behaved to
every woman because you know if a man's
moving to every woman you're just on a
one night thing but if you're persistent
keep coming up to me and i'm seeing the
way you respond and behavior and women
i'd know what kind of guy you want i
wouldn't come up to you at the start of
the night unless i was gonna stay with
you though so if you're bouncing around
you you've then eliminated absolutely
exactly no girl wants the one who's
getting with 10 goals on a night yeah
exactly you've got to pick one or two
have you ever been in the club and
wanted just a one-night thing with
someone you must have had a one-time no
i've never had one
that sounds mad i'm going to right but
not yet you've never done that though no
but i think as well though
i don't get fulfilled by that i wouldn't
get fulfilled by that because i believe
in energy exchange
right
i get what you're saying absolutely so
you believe that energy exchanges no
no
no if it's passionate and like there's
feelings there then yes i feel like
there is an energy exchange in you will
will have that
energy that shared energy with someone
but on a one-night stand i completely
disagree i feel like if you tried it
like
i don't mind i can fill in i can fill in
for you
there would be no energy exchange really
a one-night stand is not like there's no
feelings there at all but energy it's
sexually like even if that's that like
it's still energy exchange the amount of
girls that say to me oh i don't do one
that stands it's all a front if the
right guy comes along she like any girl
will do it i know she'd do it i'd take
her out for a few drinks after this and
i'll whack her up on the instagram
tomorrow boys
i don't watch porn i haven't watched
porn since like 14 15. really yeah
that's really good at all what pawn was
you watching um girl and girl guy and
girl but mostly golden girl okay but
literally since since
since yes you've got girls
yes since i started getting quite a lot
of girls i didn't yeah that's actually
true okay do you think you gave you
unrealistic expectations on sex
maybe i feel like there'd be a big
problem with the guys young
underdeveloped minds like myself
watching excessively watching porn no do
you know what i really respect this i
hope more young men listen to what he
has to say because it is a real big
issue and porn gives unrealistic
expectations on sex
because there are probably geezers who
are watching it three times a day which
i mean they're tugging 20 times a week
to and they think that the girl is going
to behave that way
in sex and it's so like so fabricated
it's [ __ ] it's nothing like the
actual real experience and i feel like
that's why there's a lot of
like there's a lot of sexual problems i
think from geezers who just they lose
their mind a little bit because that's
all they watch and that's what they
expect and they expect that girls are
just going to do this and do that and
some girls might not want to suck you
off but they think it's normal because
that happens in yeah you know what i
mean and things like that
it can have a bad effect for sure and i
wouldn't like my kid would not be
watching porn i don't think i'd let my
kid watch porn that's good i don't think
anyone just says here kids here's porn
there are parents who don't care
obviously yeah but i i would consciously
say i'd educate my kid i'd tell him you
don't want to be watching this just go
out and get a girl yeah i'm really glad
you said that you know like i'm really
pleasantly surprised that people are
being people wouldn't let um their 15
year old kid bring a girl or guy back to
the house when the parents are in like
they'd be like no like [ __ ] that but
then they'd let their kid go upstairs
and wank on the ipad you're better off
getting the girl back and letting them
have an actual
experience that's real i'd let my kid do
that
yeah would you really i'd say that is
better than this you're going to do it
anyway you're going to do it at house
parties behind my back so why don't you
do it i'm not going to be around i'll
leave the halves but do it in a safe
environment and learn what it actually
is what sex is actually about not
this this fabricated version that all
your mates are wanking over ah that's
really interesting and it would also
build confidence in the kid as well kids
who wank a lot have got no confidence
yeah in actual
meeting girls and and romanticizing them
they've got no actual brain to it
because they think porn is real life sex
right so you'd let your son do that what
if you had a daughter nope
no chance so you're the i would not let
like i would be so strict with my
daughter i would not let her i might
actually this is a compliment i would
want my daughter to come out like you
but i would want my daughter to come out
with respect for herself if my daughter
was a hoe at sorry not home um another
woman i would be so like i'd be
heartbroken
oh my god that's like the best
compliment ever
there's different educations because i
believe in the traditional setup like
you said no serious guy is going to find
um a ghost left with 50 50 guys
attractive
no no guy is going to take that goal
seriously so do i want my daughter to
just be a bike no so imagine if you said
the same thing with your son about
consent about sex don't sleep around
respect your partner
um i feel like a little bit you turn out
like a fanny though like you don't want
you don't want your kids at all you need
to you need to take this goal on a date
before you do this with them because
then you get the girls who come along
and and my my son would just be a simp
who gets the piss taken out of him who
takes the girls on the dates and then
after the dates they go to the clubs and
they get they end up getting someone
like me i'd rather my son being the guy
who isn't just wasting his money chasing
girls i'm i'd only be spending money on
girls if that was my serious girlfriend
i teach some respect i wouldn't be
wouldn't be one of these people who are
disrespectful to girls don't be watching
pawn if you wanna if you like this girl
chat to her ask find out her interests
flirt with her and then sleep with her i
know i say a lot of jokes but my son
will not be a simp like that will be the
worst thing that could possibly happen
he will not be a simp as simple as i'm
going to educate him from young tell him
exactly what he needs to be doing to get
gal like his father
but i just say how it is he's going to
be doing it anyway i'd rather he does it
in the right way
how did you get big on like social media
uh i mean it all started from i was at
university i was just looking at the
fitness industry wanting to get into
that
started a business the training is
business because i was like right i
don't want to do uni i did not attend a
lecture at all literally none i thought
how can i make money started doing
training programs because i was
obviously big i was good in the gym made
no money in the first lap few days of it
launched it and i was i was so
disappointed i was almost close to
giving up
um and then i started going live and
doing it on live stream made mad money
at the time for me like 300 quid and
alive which was like i was i thought i
was a millionaire literally i was like
oh my god like this is crazy
got enough money to go to marbella
started doing live streams talking to
girls down the strip
i got famous for talking to girls that
was it and then the way i made money was
through just monetizing my physique and
what i could do to other people's
physiques does it ever affect your
mental health
it's interesting because i was talking
about i was talking to this uh tomorrow
to ed about this the other day i feel
like the journey to getting somewhere is
way more happy than when you're there
and i feel like i was actually happier a
year ago when i was like trying to grind
and stuff it happened so fast to me like
making like quite a lot of money and
blowing up quite quickly and
i don't know if i fully lack
if i've adapted to it even if i know
what's actually happened because it
happened so far so overnight i started
making good dough so i think mental
health would i'm obviously not depressed
i'm happy i love what i've done but i
can't grasp it yeah i haven't like my
brain hasn't really understood it yet
weird and it sounds like it's bollocks
but it genuinely is like i don't know if
it's because it happened too fast or
what it is but i was probably like
as a whole happier when i was seriously
grinding trying to like
get a thousand likes on instagram so i
mean do you find there comes a lot of
pressure
my life just falls into place so if i'm
nervous before something i always think
to myself what has happened so far
that's been bad
not nothing's really nothing's pushing
me back everything i do ends up being a
positive so i just go into it and just
see what happens because it always comes
out well i could have been
thinking oh what happens today before
this before we spoke but i just i
literally when he asked me earlier i was
i'm not nervous i know it will go it
will end up going well
so it's that that sort of mindset helps
yeah you're feeling like
pressured and anxious and stuff i feel
like just just whatever happens happens
mindset is the best thing to do would
you say you're emotionally available
what do you mean what does that even
mean like when was the last time you
cried
i think the last time i cried was when
probably when i thought i was getting
nicked to be honest when was that a few
years ago we've had that was like the
most emotional time ever like we went on
a walk together and just started crying
together we thought we [ __ ] it all
um
but i don't really i don't cry at little
things if something if if my mum passed
away touch touchwood i ain't would but
whatever um i would be crying
if something awful happened to any of my
family my friends i'd cry for sure okay
that's good um i'm not someone who's
gonna sit and no i don't cry like that
it's not tough to not cry if something
affects you cry yeah but just
nothing would affect me to that level
apart from like a serious a serious bad
thing happening yeah it's a good way to
be if you hold all your emotions and it
ends up coming out in the wrong way
eventually it will just build up and
you'll have a an outburst of emotions
that is not
like if you just split it up when
something happens deal with it move on
don't keep it all up because i think
that's how
a lot of depression starts as well if
you don't vocalize what's going wrong or
speak to people or
be in tune with your emotions like you
said then
i think if you're trying to deal with it
all yourself that's how a lot of
depression starts yeah i think a lot of
people can listen to you there
yeah
i'm really impressed i was not expecting
this
standout tv
not bad not bad
what would you do if i we had a one
night stand and i got pregnant um i
would well if you wanted to keep the
baby i'm assuming you want to keep the
baby
well then i'd support it um i'd support
you i would have feelings for you
because you have my kid
and i'd make sure that the kid had a
good life i'd like i'd be friends with
you that was that would be i know i said
earlier i wouldn't be friends with a
woman but that would be the one scenario
where i would be because we both have um
a joint interest and a joint care for
the kids so i'd be friends with you for
life to be honest i'd probably make sure
you were living close to wherever i was
and i take care of both you
even if you like if you had a kid and i
didn't want it or it was like a bad
circumstance i'd still take care of you
and the kid i'd want to be on good terms
you i wouldn't want to bring the kid up
with us arguing or anything like that
yeah that's good that's a really
responsible thing it's not my fault it's
not the kid's fault is it i'm not going
to abandon him it's not his fault or her
fault yeah
okay imagine now we're together yeah
what would you do if i've slept with one
of your friends
we wouldn't be together like that
wouldn't happen i i couldn't do that no
that's too uh it's just too close to i
don't want to know anyone you've slept
with if i saw someone you slept with
when i'm when i'm out i wouldn't like it
that'd be a bit of an issue yeah so it's
like
if it's one of my friends who's around
that just would never happen like that
couldn't i couldn't physically be in
that situation anyone who does is weird
as well like anyone who let like one of
their mates as has tapped that bird that
is weird
what would you do if i didn't go to the
gym and i lived an unhealthy lifestyle
i'd change that i think unhealthy
lifestyles are really unattractive like
mcdonald's all that [ __ ] eating that not
going gym
even if the goal's in shape i know girls
that are in shape that live that sort of
lifestyle but you wouldn't live that
with me because
it's just not what i live at all you
just wouldn't do that you'd be eating
good foods i'd just educate you okay
you'd put me on i'll put you on the good
food yeah okay
what would you do if i made you wait for
the first six months of our relationship
uh did you actually think that would
happen though yeah
you're joking
no you think i'll be there even after
one month
you wouldn't wait even a month no like
two free dates max what yeah but you
could do one day a week that's a month
you've got three dates for me like three
dates over the course of three weeks
even that is pushing you'd have to be
sick i don't even know if i'd put up for
that really you don't have to be like
seriously something special for me to
take you on free dates and not
get anywhere she's a joke man for
thinking i'd wait even longer than a
month realistically it'd be a one night
thing but on a six months she she is
joking like it's just it's so out there
it's just never gonna happen i would
never chase a girl for six months just
to get a bit of [ __ ] ever and anyone
who does do that
simp
no no good there's only so much you can
talk about each day yeah it's it's yeah
there are it gets to the point where it
becomes like a bit small talk and like
if i'm not i wouldn't want to be doing
that if i wasn't if i wasn't hitting for
sure okay but what if you saw that woman
is someone serious to be away yeah but
what's our reason to wait six months if
you can you can wait six months with me
you don't you don't fancy me enough no
joe as well because this is an issue
right so men sit and call women hoes
flags skits whatever you want to list
today so if i'd slept with you easily
right so if i if every guy didn't wait
six months and i'm just dating and
having sex with everyone then my body
account is going to go high high higher
and then i'm not going to be rated
either way it's like you can't win as a
woman the answer to that is don't go on
a date unless you're trying to hold
their word yeah but go on a date and
wait six but we it's it's a long process
to know if we like them because no one
wants to take six months to like to
learn if you want to sleep with someone
you would not sleep with it really takes
an hour
no but okay but if you don't want to
just sleep with someone and you want
something serious yeah it's a long-term
thing i feel like it takes no longer
than three days i feel like i'd know you
very very well after three of three
proper days no you can get an idea on
what someone's like but to like for the
way i see it in order for me to give you
my body i want to know how you think
what makes you think why do you act like
that like it's a deeper level like when
you want something serious it's a deeper
thing than just like what was it dump
and pump or whatever
what i'm considering is i would do that
yes but i'd be sleeping with other girls
over them six months just like one of
things i would wait to sleep with one
girl if she was special
for six months whatever but six months
is a drag i don't think so but if i was
sleeping with other girls and i thought
you know what i'm going to end up wifing
this girl because she's that special
then yeah i'd wait it wouldn't matter to
me i'd take you on some dates get to
know i'd find it quiet
i like playing the game i like chasing
it's not
no but i like i like chasing so
yeah i'd do it but i'm not a muppet so i
wouldn't be not not sleeping with other
girls because i'm going on dates with
you i'd be doing that i'd be going out
and doing my thing but then yeah every
saturday night we'd go on a date and i'd
get closer and closer
what would you do if i went on a girl's
holiday every other month
just depends what you were doing there
to be honest if you're dancing in the
club like a respectful girl i don't
really care
no
i don't really care if you're like i'm
confident in myself i'm confident that
i'm worth more than just shagging some
other good-looking guy on a one-off down
ibfar
i mean yeah but it would
and i'd be in a sort of relationship
where i would end up finding out that
someone would say oh my girlfriend is
cheating on me like here or whatever
life is about having fun as well it's
not just in your relationship you're
locked indoors you can't do [ __ ] all
because there's other guys there like i
don't care if there's other guys there
i'm confident that you'd prefer me and
you'd value me over that so
yeah if you want to go on holiday fine
whatever i'll do it do what you want
literally do what you want
harrison how do you think you've done on
a date
just i've just shown who i am so
wherever you like if you like me or you
don't like me i've just done myself i've
stayed true to myself
so i don't know i've it's not been a
dead date i mean it's the combo's been
flowing so i think it was all right yeah
yeah it's been nice have you enjoyed
yourself i've enjoyed myself yeah good
yeah it's fun
do you think you're gonna get a second
date i'd be surprised if i wasn't really
i'd be surprised yeah confident then
like i said 100 success rate i didn't
think it was going to change today
you're funny you're funny
i'm really impressed i can't lie
it was good it was actually interesting
it was a good conversation it flowed
well she's an intelligent girl so that's
why it was all right i think she got to
know more about me than i did about her
but that's for the second day
i don't even think i grilled him that
much that's the thing i feel like when
they bring a good
conversation i find it really hard to
actually grill them
the grilling was i did get grilled at
some points but i think it was good i
think it went well
listen i do think he was honest in some
points but like he said he sells dreams
so i'm not falling for nothing
who knows i'd say a seven i would guess
that she'd give me a seven i'd be
disappointed with less than that
to be honest
oh i would hate to disappoint you
harrison
um
i'm gonna give you
let me see
i like the way you think i like that
you're business-minded i don't like the
way you call women slags skets hoes or
whatever so that you can work on that
and i felt like you sold me some dreams
however
all round it was a really good day so
i'm gonna give harrison a 7.7
you